hello everybody and welcome to the
beginning of the stock analysis trading
and back testing series I'm kind of
making a new beginning to the series of
the original series started with the
back testing which I think was kind of
hopping in a little too quick so I'm
going to be making some new videos here
to begin this series and what we're
going to be doing is starting with the
absolute basics which is it starting
with acquiring some prices so where are
we going to actually get the prices and
then once we have the prices what are we
going to do with them generally people
are going to want to display it somehow
so obviously you could just like put it
into like an excel sheet and display or
we can use the charting capabilities of
Python that comes with matplotlib and I
do have a full matplotlib series on my
channel as well so I will be showing you
guys at least some of the basics in this
series so with that let's go ahead and
get started we're going to begin with
just acquiring some prices so obviously
there's a lot of ways you can get prices
you can either buy prices like if you
want really really high granularity
basically of prices you're gonna have to
pay for that usually but probably later
on I'll be showing you guys where you
can go to get some really high quality
data absolutely for free but that's
going to be in a later video and so many
ways how can we actually just begin
getting some some data so we're going to
use Yahoo which actually gives us a bit
of an API I'm not really sure if they
mean to leave this here all the time or
what but let me give you guys an example
of the Yahoo API so if we open up our
browser and one set and within our
browser we have I guess I'll move this
over so you can see the full link but
you know we'll be typing it out anyways
but its chart API dot finance Taiyo com
an instrument and then right here this
is kind of code for you can put any
stock you want in this link and then
over here you can well it's going to
give us quote nothing there but here is
another thing that you can edit so like
we could say one year and that's going
to give us one day open high/low close
or you can do something as small as like
10 d for 10 days and that will give us I
think it's every five minutes but we'll
see in just a second so let's say we
highlight this and we do a APL hit enter
and now let me pull this over here you
see there's some stuff up here that we
don't want but then pretty quickly we
get into these just raw data here and as
you can see it's once a day six seven
eight and then the weekend and then
again 11 12 13 14 15 weekend and so on
and we've got you know obviously the
date here it's in a funky format but
I'll show you guys how we can work
around that if we want to graph it and
then we've got some numbers here
I forget what I think it's like open low
high let's see what it is close high low
open and then volume and then yes I will
also be showing you guys how we can even
chart volume in a typical volume chart
and probably will do at least like
moving averages and maybe some other
basic forms of analysis that I'll show
you guys how to do but a lot of people
want to do like their specific stuff but
we'll get to it so anyway this is how we
are going to acquire the data we're just
going to be using this chart API from
Yahoo another thing I'll just show you
real quick is what Yahoo does and kind
of throws you a curve ball as you can
see the date is kind of like written out
here right it's 2012 I put in one year
right so it's a year from today and then
Oh 8 which is our month and then the
27th which is our day but as soon as you
go for higher granularity like let's say
we do instead of one year we do 10 days
hit enter oops we attendee
he's going to read that uncap suit okay
now you see all of a sudden that it's
giving us these funky funky numbers here
now if you're not familiar with
programming this is a quality UNIX
timestamp and so we're going to have to
convert that timestamp in to you know
date time format that we can then plot
which again I will be showing you guys
how to do so don't worry but this data
is a little bit better granularity as
you can see it is well UNIX timestamp
the way it works is it's a count of
seconds after January 1st 1970 so
basically it's in seconds so this goes
to 99 then $5.99 so 300 seconds and so
the granularity here is 300 divided by
60 which is actually 5 so it's 5 minutes
open high low close data and volume so
actually it's pretty good data it's not
good enough if you want to do like high
frequency training though I think
there's a lot less people interested in
doing high frequency trading with stocks
you need a lot of money to do it's not
very efficient unless you're extremely
wealthy but some people still do it and
so maybe that's what you want in that
case you'd need to buy your own data but
if you're extremely wealthy enough to
high frequency trades stocks chances are
you can afford to buy the data so I
don't know why you won't be watching
this video
so anyways up that's just some of the
basics of this Yahoo API there are other
ways to acquire data and as we getting
further into this I will be showing you
guys some data that's a lot higher
granularity and pretty good quality data
but that's going to be for some more
advanced tutorials for sure so to start
off this is the data that we're going to
use and so yeah let's go ahead and get
started so to begin this tutorial the
only thing that you're going to need is
the Python programming language if you
don't have the Python programming
language never fear I will show you guys
how to download it so what you're gonna
want to do is open up your browser let
me drag mine down and you're going to
want to find your way to python.org and
once you're there you're going to want
to go to the downloads section once you
get to the download page you'll see that
there's actually two versions of Python
there's two seven at
and then obviously 3.3 X and the one
that we want is 2/7 now depends on you
know what operating system you're on as
far as what you download I will just
mention that if you're on if you have a
64-bit operating system you could
download the 32 but definitely get this
64 because it's gonna help you out later
if you're on Windows then just click on
the windows install that's pretty easy
it'll download this Python to 7 MSI all
you'll have to do is just run through
the Installer is really really simple
just run through it I've already
installed it so I'm not going to go
install it again but yeah it's very
basic installation once you're done you
should be able to go to like your Start
bar and type in like python and you
should be able to click something that
comes up and looks something like this
but it's probably going to look maybe a
little different but at the top you
should see that you're running Python 2
point something point whatever and it
should look something close to this
might say 32-bit and you know your
operating system might be different but
anyway let's say you're going to install
Python if you're uncomfortable with
Python or how to use Python I'll try to
go kind of slow through these tutorials
but I do have a lot of Python tutorials
in my channel so if you're lagging
behind or maybe you want to learn a bit
more about a specific topic definitely
definitely check out my channel and the
other videos that I cover on the Python
programming language since it's pretty
much my main language that I use I
really like it so with that I'm going to
conclude this video in the next video
we're going to be beginning to pull that
data from Yahoo and I'll show you guys
how to do some really cool stuff with
Python and pulling the data and then
later on we'll be charting in and then
doing some basic analysis so as always
thank you for watching thanks for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time